quella tutti ragazzi benvenuto che sono
video sono fa vj oggi siamo in un altro
episodio di limbo così dopo una visione
inglese
ap vision è per i gio spero che muove il
culo mo vicolo moby culo mob il culo
nuovi culo e non ci arrivo a lo devo
spingere ancora più indietro capito dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai zio d'aids
io non ci credo mai non ci credo ma
guardo fatto a caso alla fine non sono
anche riuscito a tema bene c'è una si
sta capovolgendo tutto e c'è una roccia
sotto di me quindi perfetto mischia
c'era la roccia quanto è vero iddio l'ho
presa però che culo
vai vai no non dire addio monti lazio la
roll a roccia era quasi vera la mia
previsione ma non del tutto
se passo prima che la roccia mischiarci
forse le riescono non mi ha schiacciato
ok ok non è non era come pensavo ma va
bene stato non vedo assolutamente nulla
ma qua sopra
non prendo la scossa no il cazzo sta
andando ragazzo
non vedo niente a era uno dei colleziona
e il teatro il primo che prendono il gio
anzi nel secondo che prendo in tutti i
video di video che ho fatto di lingua il
primo che prendono i collezionabili
finissima questo vi fa capire quanto io
ami completare i giochi al cento per
cento ragazzi anche in inside era così
era pieno di collezionabili non ho mai
preso mezzo già è difficile finire un
videogioco per me figuriamoci fare i
collezionabili
ok è un laser nonno lager
nola non è un laser faccio qualcosa di
sotto non ci arrivò mai dall'altra parte
muoio prima
madonna ragazzine anche in terminator
robe così era giusto giusto non è giusto
a meno che non debba mitragliare la
mitraglia in basso portando l'altra così
potrebbe
[Musica]
perfetto che ha un genio non ci casco
fuma e basta la voglio veder esplodere
eccolo limitrofe lo sapevo io che
l'avrei presa nel caveau anzi lo stesso
ho visto una [ __ ] un'ora fa
non l'ho mai più mai più vista proprio
mai più cos'è ok
in teoria in teoria michia pensavo mi
schiacciasse guarda perfetto madonna
quanta ansia bene in teoria doveva ce
l'ha fatta
poi tra l'altro non ho capito perché le
casse sono scola gravità e io no
ha forse perché magnetismo non è gravità
ok scusate l'avevo capito io non sono
magnetico non so il pene di ferro non so
reach
ok illuminatemi a cosa dovrebbe
servirgli con la roma l'ha
cazzo ci arrivo per nulla ragazzi mi
chiara e vabbè anno sono morte 20
addetti forza zio forza veloce
ok stavolta ce la faccio è pronto ce la
faccio perfetto yes a chi addirittura
vabbè ce l'ho fatta è vero che quanto
tempo addirittura pensavo di non farcela
maglia invece perfect sono veramente
vedere dell'erba mi rincuora un sacco
non so perché eravamo botto che lo
vedevo l'erba
anche quante mitraglie che palle
sicché ansia che devo fare
va bene ci sono gli alberi addirittura
gli alberi e va beh veramente l'altro è
una figata perché gli alberi sono al
contrario e vabbè mica devo portare una
scatola sicurissimo ed a far scendere la
scatola ragazzi non so come ma devo
farlo a scendere quindi suo affetto a ok
chiaro grazie forse non lo so è che
cassa è quella di piombo non pensavo mi
reggesse il colpo bene va bene non
credevo mi leggesse il colpo dei
proiettili perfetto si sta roba
ok come faccio
ma almeno se finisco la mia carriera da
youtuber faccio il portapacchi che
comunque è utile però devo essere di una
precisione millimetrica ragazzi tipo
fare tipo fare così
ecco lei ora io la precisione
millimetrica non siamo la stessa cosa
forse sì cazzo ma forse così riesco si
si si
vai vai vai vai ok niente la precisione
millimetrica me la sono mangiata a
colazione ragazzi poi ci ho messo un
anno e mezzo per arrivare in st foresta
stupida ci ho messo una vita
son riuscito a fare una roba decente una
volta una ecco forse sarà anche l'ultima
che si sta roba ragazzi sono
non è vero non è vero
james bond signori james bond è un po
dei poveri però visto città dove si
abbassa che gli dà lo slancio giusto dai
frate ce l'ho fatta mica james bond
fermi tutti gente che vive nel limbo
guardate fuori dalla finestra perché non
vedrete mai più cose così ed è gratis
pure porca eva quanto figo
non ci credo di aver fatto veramente
questa cosa
ok bene no a punti orgasmi sto lanciando
in questo game play ok perfetto dove
vado helmi madonna come visto salvato
che culo vai frate vai frate c'era una
cera cos'è una ciambella una ciambella
gigante ok non so cosa serva non fare
domande vai vai vai vai tu vai fotte
sega ok
minchia vai zio vai zio veloce però non
ci passo vero non ci credo
puzzano l'anno calcolato apposta l'anno
calcolato per farmi incazzare apostolo
hanno calcolato dio santero quante robe
quanto schifo visto gioco cosa loro
basta guardare a saperlo ma cos'è sta
roba perché cambiare gravità ogni tre
secondi aiuto cazzo vuoi che faccia
spiega me non posso andare qua e basta
adesso lusso cade no a mi chiamerà
semplice era più semplice di quanto
pensassi oriente prima lo finiamo sto
gioco
vediamo prima meglio il futuro è bello
come gioca veramente bello però giuro su
dio blue card è facile cacciare
a chi è palle ok ok ok è come faccio qui
è impossibile perché non ho capito
perfetto
vai giù frate va giù perfetto o basta è
sta roba della gravità basta ma cagate
un cazz.o famigli parte da lì quanto è
vero iddio ti ammazzo te non era
possibile regalo
ok perfetto mica anche riuscito al primo
tentativo anzi secondo prova bene ok non
di quasi simpatico e lo schiacciare la
leva s eleva schiaccerà mai perfetto non
schiaccerà un cazzo che non debba far
così va dove lo stanno facendo cosa
stavo facendo una roba incredibile stavo
facendo
vai subito stiamo parti vai o più
slancio di così si muore
vabbè mi chiamate x8 ho rotto un vetro
miglio e uno era un vetro uno specchio
era uno specchio la sfiga e vabbè
lasciamo se la prende lui non io e stato
lui io non ho fatto niente perché para
lenti che si stanno va da fare qualcosa
sono morto michael jackson
[Musica]
pollice in su e via
spiegami con il problema era lenti ci
portò via tutta quanta la giornata però
sta durando troppo se sono morto non è
possibile
sono vivo figata veramente un capitolo o
dio santo quanto tempo per trovare sacco
anzi li prendi per il culo l'altra volta
pasta e federica la mano amica forever
cioè io te lo dico a raleigh mi sono
fatti ralenti per arrivare da the viral
intense anche per un bel unità all anno
sono capelli quelli che tristezza
dino patti cambia nome fra te che cazzo
di cos'era suo finale cosa mi
rappresenta
cosa mira chi era quella ma l'avevo
visto anche la prima veramente sii serio
e finito così porca vacca lytham ignota
ma veramente finito così non mi
ricordavo mai che finiva così mi ricorda
un fine diverso mi cosano tra noi amico
l'ha completamente altre cover è
bellissimo ovunque alla faccia un test
ve lo avevo detto all'inizio alimenti
allo stesso trascurati i capelli come la
samp e per quelli di voi che hanno visto
inside che è lo stesso che un gioco
fatto dalla stessa casa di produzione di
limbo preferite questo limbo o inside
scrivetelo nei commenti
adesso in questo momento scritte mine
commenti avete preferito limbo o inside
adesso si chiede in questo momento non
guardate cosa dico dopo perché se non ha
senso reso the fat elo questo è uscito
prima di inside ok uscito prima quindi
questo è uscito 2010 tipo 2011 ricorda
inside è uscito al 2016 e tutti quelli
che hanno giocato a limbo prima di
inside hanno detto che limbo è più bello
di inside quindi questo avete appena
visto è più bello di inside tutti quelli
che hanno girato prima al limbo se avete
risposto che vi è piaciuto di più inside
vuol dire che alla fine non è non è vero
è semplicemente perché inside all è
giocato prima perché questo perché ogni
volta tipo che ne so
molti mi dite è un esperimento fido
perché molti mi dicono tipo a quella
volta quando ero piccolo quella roba era
meglio oppure che ne so anche su di me
tipo era fa vj trani fare meglio adesso
se cambiando se diverso la verità è che
se io fossi stato così come mi vedete
voi 45 anni fa sarebbe stato meglio
semplicemente voi mi conoscevate quel
come il per come ero prima eravate
abituati a quello è quello che vi fa
dare il voto aggiuntivo quindi il voto
preferenziale e la nostalgia e basta è
solo la nostalgia perché sono vi sarebbe
piaciuto di più limbo da solo rigo per
certo perché il 95 per cento avevano
fatto un sondaggio non mi ricordo dove
ma al 95 per cento delle persone che
avevano giocato a limbo prima aveva
detto che inside era bello ma meno bello
di limbo se voi avete risposto in
maggioranza inside e perché
effettivamente la nostalgia fa effetto
sul voto preferenziale perché in realtà
in per molti più bello limbo ma vera
gazzoli spero vi sia piaciuto questo
full gameplay di
di limbo che ho fatto tra l'altro con da
tosse morta ho tagliato 3 miliardi di
pezzi in cui tossivo a bronchite
comunque sia ragazzi spero che questo
che vi sia piaciuto conto tv ha bisogno
al momento è un mi piace anche vari
social che come iscrizione senza vestiti
16 clicchiamo un prossimo limbo da
ragazzi